lener after four rounds going into the
first rest day give us your assessment
of your performance and uh tell us a bit
about yesterday's game as well because
that one was pretty
wild yeah uh obviously a big chance for
me yesterday um but um yeah other than
that um pretty solid pretty normal I
mean I had three blacks uh so I guess
it's fine um but yeah yesterday game was
was uh very interesting I uh I was a
Pity not to win because I would would
have been one of my best games I think
but that Queen to F6 at the end very and
uhor that Queen to F6 idea at the end
Rook to E3 and queen to F6 did you see
it during the analysis did you see it
did your did the computer show it to you
after the
game yeah of course I mean I saw it
after the game but during the game I was
kind of I mean was aware of it but um of
course I um it never really came to my
mind to play this uh rooky 3 I mean I
was considering um just briefly because
I mean the main issue was that I had so
little time and you can always lose this
position so I was uh I mean uh once I
got down to less than two minutes I was
a bit bit in a panic mode and um just
briefly thought about the queen F6 but
always with the Rook on E1 one I mean
not not with the Rook on E3 so there was
always takes takes King H7 uh but yeah
this Rook E3 was brilliant and of course
there there were many um I mean there
were few other ways to win but yeah it
was tough with little time I think this
BX A4 was brilliant uh uh from him
because I was thinking it's just I'm
going to M him and he he canot do
anything but yeah suddenly he found the
best defensive and then at least yeah
and even A5 I mean I was really shocked
by if5 I thought I was just ma him and
he goes A5 I mean the pawn is still so
far but uh it was winning but yeah it
wasn't so simple absolutely well three
blacks only one white and you had a
great chance with the white pieces that
is a good sign for your form lenir go
get some rest during the rest day guys
any questions for yeah oh geez
absolutely uh lanir uh first of all yeah
sorry for the Miss yesterday that Queen
F6 would have been absolutely brilliant
we were looking at your game because of
the whole sacrifice and we were
mystified by two suggestions of the
computer one suggestion involved your
playing A5 A4 first question was that a
uh a move you considered secondly the
other suggestion of the computer was to
play for Rook G8 which actually makes a
lot of sense because there's no longer
the repetition you would have Rook G6 in
case of Queen G3 uh did either of those
two moves or maybe both uh catch your
eye I mean A4 I didn't think about it at
all uh just a way too too deep for me I
mean the position it's already very
complex there like many options for both
sides and it's it's hard to tell for for
humans here uh what's what's right and
what what's not uh Rook d8 was indeed a
very logical way and I was considered in
the move of course but I think uh um oh
instead of Queen E7 yeah no I the moves
I was considering here other than Queen
E7 were Knight
B8 uh because it's very natural I mean
very human at least to try to play
Knight B8 Knight D7 but uh first of all
I wasn't sure if D5 D5 Queen G3 and
queen takes E5 what was the the
situation there I mean um Queen G3 King
H7 Queen takes C5 I have have to play
probably Knight G4 and then yeah because
if Knight D7 there is Queen F5 check so
Knight G4 obviously and then Queen H5
and uh I wasn't sure at all I mean maybe
black is okay here but uh Queen E8 or
something but
uh but uh wild yeah Rook G8 uh was was
indeed logical
um I was just worried that I would never
get rid of this pin and that he would
have time for Rook D1 Rook D3 but
apparently Rook D1 Rook D3 is not so
deadly and I can just stay put with the
queen on E7 and then maybe yeah maybe
even go for this uh slow play with
Bishop D7 it's very hard to to decide on
this because it looks like I'm I'm going
to to get uh to get uh mated here or
that I will lose F6 because once The
Rook gets to the third rank there are
ideas with queen E2 and then Rook F3 but
uh yeah I guess the point is Queen E2
King H7 and and then or King f8 and then
Rook G6 lenar this reminds me that Sam
savian was saying that he felt he's
putting his opponent into Eternal pain
but he doesn't have uh ways how to
increase the pressure how did you feel
in that position with that pain were you
in Eternal pain
pain yes so that's why I was uh trying
to to find ways to to solve it to get
rid of the pin but it turns out that I I
didn't have to worry about it so much
but yeah uh it's it's a very difficult
position for both sides because white is
obviously running some risk as well I
mean if things go wrong um he's indeed
down a piece but uh at the same time for
black it's also unpleasant especially if
you have to uh be cool and not worry at
all and just put Queen on E7 and play
like Bishop D7 Rook a A8 and so on I
think yeah uh very hard position to play
for both and I think draw is is a
logical result after all lanir thank you
so much for joining us enjoy your free
day uh you deserve it um we have update
uh with the ladies now that tatev has
won her game